[Music]
you have written this book why and when
the Dick Van Dyke Show was born and this
show was such a game-changer and what's
what I loved about this book and I've
been through every page as you talk
about the unlikely path to success of
this show your wife Estelle was the one
who pushed you to write this show you
were reluctant because you hadn't you'd
written sketch comedy but you hadn't
written this kind of format before and
you didn't think you could do it well
right after the show of shows ended was
with Sid Caesar and Cesar's hour at the
review format was dead until Carol
Burnett brought it back yeah and so I
was being offered situation comedies and
they weren't very good at my wife read
one she wanted to write when I don't
have to write that I was on Fire Island
and I said to myself what piece of
ground do I stand on that nobody stands
on I live in New Rochelle work in New
York on a variety show
so I'll write about that I wrote a thing
called head and the family and was
financed by Peter Lawford he paid for
the pilot and I wrote 13 episodes that
happened ready in case went on the other
writers would have a template and so I
did the pilot with Barbara Britton and
Morty Gundy and silver miles it was fair
it was okay and you were that you were
the star I played Robert Petry it was oh
okay
didn't sell and I started doing movies I
wrote a movie for DARS day at the front
look at all
and Sheldon Leonard got a hold of these
13 scripts from my agent and he said he
called me and he says these are very
good I said well Sheldon I don't want to
fail twice with the same material and
Here I am personally in pretty well he
says you won't fail I'll get a better
actor to play you
[Laughter]
and then answers Dick Van Dyke huh you
know what's so funny is you see how much
the times have changed
you have Dick Van Dyke Mary Tyler Moore
and they're married on the show but you
can't show them in bed together oh the
the the this the restrictions and the
sort of puritanical sexual code was so
intense in the early 60s well in the 50s
it was even worse Syd Caesar on the show
of shows and I were in the trenches
during World War one as playing two
soldiers and the bombs are bombing us
and Syd raises fists and he says damn
you damn you damn you and they said you
can't say damn right so it ended up on
the air darn you
darn yeah darn you which is what you
would say if you're about to die yeah
and we could I'm a hundred years later
Joan Rivers had a show a roast show and
she asked me beyond I hated roast and
she's just be my guest please it's a her
last anyway I went on I was the guest at
the end was this televised alibi I guess
it was televised and it was also bleeped
which I'll bleep myself and and I came
up there and I said you know I told the
story about saying darn darn darn week I
said we couldn't say anything so here
now I get a chance to use all the words
I've never been allowed to use and I
went
[Applause]
and I went free free is last
[Applause]